[Music]
hello YouTube just lovers in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 13th
episode of dirty chess tricks after the
Mordor
efore Aoife in my earlier dirty chestrig
series I have recommended my own tricky
ruruta starting with the Moon Knight to
f3 now because that series get
tremendous popularity I have decided to
show you another set of tricky reputa
which will not only make you stronger
and unpredictable but it will include a
secret weapon in your armory the move I
am proposing over here is Bishop to c4
now this move has few advantages
compared to the move Knight to f3 number
one most of the black players does not
know how to play accurately against this
move and the number two is when you play
the move Knight to f3 it's not necessary
that every time black is going to play
the moonlight to c6 or the Moody 6 as
you go higher in the ranking you will
find out that that can also try this
move Knight to f6 known as better off
defense or the Russian defense has a
white if you don't have a good system
against this move then there are some
lines which are quite boring and dry so
altogether Bishop c4 avoid this nuisance
now as I have highlighted over here the
most popular responses by the black is
either 92 web 6 or Bishop to c5 but
nevertheless black has also tried on few
occasions moves such as Knight to c6 and
the d6 in this episode we are going to
concentrate on the move Bishop to c5 but
before we look at them you should know
exactly what you are going to do if you
opponent place less popular moves the
first more I want to highlight over here
is Knight to c6 well against this I am
recommending that you should continue
with the moonlight
three and if you have one and continue
here with the move Knight to f6 then yup
you enter into the max lang and the
morphe attack territory why are the
Moody fall which I have covered in
detail dirty chess tricks sixth and the
seventh episode accordingly
instead of Knight to f6 if you opponent
try the move Bishop to c5 then I'm
recommending that you should continue as
castle on the Kings side and after the
move Knight to f6 you enter into the
Italian Court livanski gambit territory
with the move d4 which I have covered in
detail
dirty chess tricks 8th episode now at
this point black and also played the
move d6
but this is less dangerous in this lines
because here obviously white is going to
continue with the Moon Knight to f3 and
doesn't matter what your opponent plays
for example light web 6 or Knight to d7
then the simplest reply is d4 and we
enter into the fiddle central attack
territory which I have covered in detail
dirty chest trick fifth episode so you
can easily see against less popular move
you have absolutely no work to do if you
have seen earlier my dirty chess tricks
video let's get to the business end
where you open and place the move Bishop
to c5 against this move I'm recommending
a very aggressive and a dangerous Lewis
gambit starting with the move d4 unlike
other gambits this gambit is pretty much
forced because black has to accept this
there is no way black and run away from
this gambit in one blitz game my
opponent try the move Bishop to d6 which
is in fact the only move to decline this
gambit but this is the clear case where
white can finish our black very very
quickly here white will continue with
the mu d captures Aoife and after Bishop
captures ePHI we have the first trick on
the table
yup is Bishop captures f7 BAM
after King kept his f7 and Queen to defy
check if black wants to hang on to his
piece then the only move left is King to
f6 at first sight it looks like Black
has saved his piece but after very quiet
but the amazing move Knight to f3 not
only white will begin his piece but
black is in a danger to losing the game
outright kindly note this Bishop cannot
move
for example if Bishop to d6 then the
simplest is Bishop to g5 it's not about
the securing the queen but blacking will
be checkmated in few moves if you want
to find out you can pause the video I'm
showing right now King to g6
Quinn - fi check and after Queen to h5
g4 is actually a checkmate so in the
game my opponent spotted this and he
played the obvious move that is Queen -
eh coming out from the all the danger
and same time saving his piece but no
matter still white can finish the black
very very quickly here I continue with
the move Bishop to g5 check and after
the MU King to g6 the amazing blue
Knight captures ePHI and black is
completely lost he continued with the
move King captures Bishop but the end is
very near I responded with the move
Knight to g4 discover check from the
Queen and after the following moves
black King find out in a very miserable
position so there is a threat of Queen
to a5 checkmate my opponent thought that
he can stop it with the Moody 6 but
after White's next move that is Queen to
g5 there are 2 ways if I can checkmate
lacking and black cannot stop both of
them the games can be finished very very
quickly if your opponent plays passive
moves such as Bishop to d6
so here it is very clear that black has
to accept the pawn now the question is
which way he should accept the first
obvious and the blunder movies he
catches d4 which I bet many of you open
and if they have seen this position
first time they will definitely turn out
this move now no price for guessing
White's next move it is very obvious
Bishop captures f7 BAM number two after
King takes and Queen check not only
white will regain his peace
but black ink is clearly misplaced and
on top of that white is threatening to
capture another pawn so black response
is force black has to play the move
Knight to c6 and here white will
continue with the move Knight to f3
pressurizing more to the d4 pawn now
many a times even in the rapid and
classical game black players does this
mistake that is the move d6 which is in
fact turn out as a blunder the simple
repetition is white will play the move
Queen to defy check and now when the
King moves white will gain the d4 pawn
kindly note black cannot play the move
Bishop to e6 because of the simple
repetition Knight to g5 and black will
lose a piece so d6 is not a good move at
this point the main move over here is
Knight to f6 attacking the e4 but White
has a very simple reply over here and
that is to castle on the Kings side this
move simply prevent the move Knight to
e4 because if black foolishly play
Knight to e4 at this point then after
Queen to defy check black we lose that
night so most obvious continuation is
rook to e8 afterwards I'm proposing that
white should capture this d4 pawn I get
this position in one of the rapid game
where my opponent continue with the Moon
Knight captures Knight Queen captures
and now rook captures efore attacking
the Queen
no matter I calmly retrieve my queen
back to the d1 and black continue with
the move defy developing his last minor
piece at first sight it looks like black
is doing very good but perception can be
deceptive here I continue with the Moon
Knight to c3 attacking the rook so rook
drop backs then I played the Bishop to
g5 hitting the knight
so there is a pressure on the d5 square
so my opponent defended with the move c6
and I centralized my queen with the d4
although the material is balanced White
has a very easy to play where black is
hard-pressed to find a plan or the
counter-attack hear my opponent continue
with the move Bishop to d7 I responded
with the move rook to even and after
rook captures and rook captures black is
in the completely hopeless position look
at that key stuck in the center the
night is completely pinned down the
Queen cannot come to the e-file and
those pathetic rook and the bishop they
are not even participating in the game
completely frustrated by his position my
opponent churn out with the move B file
but there is a rule in chess when you
are in the bad shape you do not make a
very see moves and this is exactly the
case over here before I proceed I like
you to pause this video and find out
amazing blue which can finish off the
black okay I hope you find this move
that is Knight catice defy complete
demolition job so from all this vidiian
we can easily conclude over here that
the only move black can have is Bishop
captures default well after this move
right we'll continue with the move
Knight to f3 hitting the bishop and if
the bishop moves then the e5 pawn draw
now as I have highlighted over here
black has tried three different choices
but amongst them if you open and place
the move Knight to c6
and the task is very easy because here
what will castle on the Kings side and
when black respond with the Moon Knight
to f6 we can simply capture this Bishop
can you remember this position yup
this is one of the transposition occurs
from Italian coat Lewinsky gambit which
I have covered in detail
dirty chess tricks eight episode so
those of you who haven't watched that
video I insist them to watch that video
and find out some amazing tricks exist
in this line the second move black and
try over here is Quint we have six now
when this gambit was invented even some
of the Masters get attracted towards
this gambit and they have tried in their
game the game I'm about to show you
which was played by Staunton and coach
irani who are some of the very famous
players and the game continued with the
MU castle on the Kings side black
responded with the move Bishop to b6
and white continue with the move Knight
to c3 so you can already see why it has
a tremendous position and this game will
give you a very good illustration if
black does not play carefully even the
very highest rated players can be
demolished very very quickly here
obviously black responded with the MU c6
stopping knight intrusion but that leads
to a big disaster I give you as an
exercise can you find a Mordor which
will completely give upper hand to the
white okay I hope you find this whoa
that is Bishop to g5 so Queen has the
only square left that is g6 and after
this the amazing stunner might captures
ePHI more or less trapping the Queen so
Queen has the only force reply laughs
that is Queen captures g5 afterwards
Knight captures f7 hitting two major
pieces
when black responded with the move Queen
to see fi White has calmly played the
move Bishop to b3 so after just 10 moves
of the game one of the world-class
player getting exchanged down in Lewis
gambit with a completely losing position
that's hard and the final move black and
try over here is Knight to f6 but
against this I'm recommending that you
should capture this bishop and when
black recapture as per the max length
attack style we are going to continue
with the mu E Phi kindly note Black has
the only decent reply over here is D
file afterwards White has to give this
check that is Bishop to b5 now the King
is attacked the knight is attack and
only good mu black is having is either
to play the move c6 or Bishop to d7
black cannot play the move Knight to d7
which will be the case of many black
player but this is outright mistake the
simple repetition is Queen to g4 and
white obtain a clear advantage there are
a few funny lines over here for example
if you open place the move g6 then after
Bishop to g5 that sweetie is strapped in
the corner so that's not possible
if black castle on the King side then
after Bishop 2 at 6 there's a med
threaten on the g7 so only move to
defend the mate is to play the move g6
but after Bishop captures Knight
captures and Queen captures d4 within 11
moves white obtained and exchanged last
move black and try is King to f8 but
this is hardly describe a good move the
simple repetition is you can continue
with the move Queen captures d4 and
after the move c6 the simplest is Bishop
to e2 and black get a very funny King
side position
so all these good tricks suggest that
black has to play the move c6 or Bishop
to d7 but against each of them white
obtained a very comfortable position to
illustrate this I like to show you my
own game where my opponent continued
with the move c6 I responded with the mu
e captures f6
he grabbed my bishop I captured the g7
attacking the rook and my opponent tried
the move Queen to e7 so his idea is to
misplace my key but I have a very sneaky
reply that is Bishop to e3 and black
cannot catch this bishop because his own
room hanging so my opponent continued
with the move rook to g8 and now I get
the d4 pawn at first sight it looks like
black and developed some attack starting
with the move Knight to c6 but no matter
white can easily capture these phones
the simple reason is let's say after the
move Bishop to e6 Queen captures beefer
and castle on the Queen side yep black
is far ahead in the development but
white is rock-solid and white position
will be consolidated very very soon I
played a very important more at this
Junction that is night 2 d2 and I'm all
side to castle on the Queen side
afterwards black is really scratching
for the counter play saying that my
opponent come out with the following
water that his rook captures g7
attacking g2 no matter I responded with
the MU g3 he played the MU King to be 8
and I simply castle on the Queen side
yes black can obtain one more pawn that
is Bishop captures a 2 but after Queen
to a4 Bishop to e6 and rook to e1 not
only white obtained a wonderful position
but white is a clear point ahead and
black has some shattered pawn the King
side which is a deciding factor at the
endgame
that's it folks I hope with this amazing
analysis you can confidently play The
Bluest gambit and finish your opponent
very very quickly well thank you for
watching this wonderful video feel free
to like subscribe and comment on this
video and I will meet you in my next
lecture where I am going to concentrate
on the move Knight to f6 at this point
bye